véhicules d'occasion, les prix
ont explosé.
Ceux qui veulent s'acheter
un véhicule neuf doivent
(bruit de moteur)
- Il lui a fallu quelques mois
de démarches, mais aujourd'hui,
Harold Haché peut enfin
rouler avec la Cadillac
qu'il convoitait.
HAROLD HACHÉ
- Notre location était à terme.
Ils ont tout simplement rajouté
un 6 mois puis j'ai dit bon, ok,
on va trouver un moment donné,
sinon ça va aller à l'automne.
Donc je me considère très, très
chanceux d'avoir eu le véhicule
que je voulais.
- Parce que trouver une voiture
neuve a rarement été aussi
difficile. C'est vrai chez
le concessionnaire GM
de la rue Papineau.
PASCAL VERDY, DG
Le Relais Chevrolet Buick GMC
- Avoir aussi peu d'autos
disponibles, ne serait-ce que
pour les montrer aux clients,
c'est sûr et certain que c'est
quelque chose qu'on n'a
jamais vu.
- C'est vrai aussi chez Toyota,
sur la rue Rachel.
JOCELYN BRISEBOIS DG des ventes
Chassé Toyota
- C'est pire que j'ai jamais vu.
ha oui, définitivement,
c'est plus long avoir
les véhicules que ça l'était,
définitivement.
- Partout en Amérique du Nord,
les inventaires sont au plus
bas. Les consommateurs ont
économisé et se ruent
vers les voitures,
sauf que la production
est encore au ralenti.
JESSE CARON,
expert automobile, CAA-Québec
- On assiste un peu
à une tempête parfaite de ventes
qui est très, très forte
et d'offre qui est faible
parce que les constructeurs
ont de la difficulté
à s'approvisionner
en certaines pièces.
- C'est surtout le manque
de semi-conducteurs qui pose
problème: ces petites puces
électroniques, fabriquées en
Asie, dont la demande a explosé
pendant la pandémie,
car elles entrent aussi
dans la fabrication
de nombreux appareils
domestiques.
- Souvent, ce qui arrive,
c'est que les véhicules
sont bâtis, sont mis de côté
à l'usine, et ils attendent
de recevoir des micro-chips
pour être capables
de nous les expédier.
- Selon le modèle et la marque,
il faut donc attendre
de quelques semaines à plus
d'une année pour recevoir
son véhicule. Les camionnettes,
les VUS et les voitures hybrides
ou électriques sont
les plus attendues.
- Le fait que ça touche autant
de segments puis de modèles
dans l'industrie, ça c'est rare.
Alors le meilleur conseil qu'on
peut donner aux consommateurs,
c'est peut-être d'attendre si
c'est pas pressant de renouveler
son véhicule.
- De nombreux acheteurs se
tournent vers les véhicules
usagés faute d'en avoir un neuf.
Il y a donc, là aussi,
une grande pénurie.
WALTER NINZATTI
- Il m'a dit qu'il y a pas
beaucoup d'offres sur le marché.
Il faut attendre,
il y a une liste d'attente.
- Sur les sites de reventes
comme chez les concessionnaires,
les vendeurs ont le gros bout
du bâton et les prix
sont élevés.
- À ce temps ici, on devrait
avoir 125-130 véhicules
d'occasion, on en a 65 environ,
70. Le client va sur le marché,
il regarde combien son véhicule
vaut, nous autres, on essaie
de le prendre en échange ou de
l'acheter, faut être compétitif
parce que si on n'est pas
compétitif, il y a quelqu'un
d'autre qui va l'acheter.
- Il y a des membres
qui nous appellent
et qui nous disent des choses
comme: "J'ai un Ford F-150 que
j'ai annoncé à 21 000$ et on m'a
appelé la journée même pour me
dire vous le vendez pas assez
cher, moi je vous offre 25 000$
pour votre véhicule
instantanément! Et ça,
des appels comme ça,
on en reçoit quotidiennement.
- Le CAA appelle à la prudence.
- Il y a des bonnes affaires
à faire de ce côté là,
mais les consommateurs,
quand qu'ils veulent se départir
de leur véhicule, doivent
s'assurer que celui
qu'ils veulent acheter est bel
et bien disponible pour pas
se retrouver entre deux chaises.
- Selon les analystes,
il y aura une pénurie
de véhicules au-moins jusqu'à
la fin de l'année.
Ici Jean-Sébastien Cloutier,
Radio-Canada, Montréal